this is the room and historic florid
assembly plant in Dearborn Michigan I'm
here to live out every gearheads fantasy
seeing my new souped-up customized f-150
Raptor roll off the line and as an added
bonus I'm gonna watch how they build
every f150 the top-selling vehicle in
America I have just bought a raptor I
bought a raptor how many people does it
take to build one and how long it takes
about a thousand people and it takes
about 20 hours on a daily basis how many
trucks roll out of here about 1,250
units actually do that an equivalent of
six days a week so the best 7,000 units
a week most of the 375 robots work at
the start of the line molding steel into
a 7,000 pound truck from the bottom up
now it's off to paint in the case of my
truck that pallet is black on black more
than half the people on the line work in
final assembly here they do the integral
work of installing the guts and for a
raptor that means getting extra large
engine and special shots the last stop
before shipment for your standard f150
is quality control but for my Raptor and
other specialized trucks they go to
modification or the mod center they put
on the graphics packages that really
differentiate that sucks visually that
helped them stand out I opted for $2,000
in hand-laid decals after getting a
first-hand look at the manufacturing
process it was time for the real reason
I flew all the way out to Michigan to
see my very own
is that it oh my god I can't believe it
that's the best customer service ever
had the CEO delivered my car to me don't
worry man unbelievable I cannot believe
I did not expect this
it's amazing you picked up really nice
tow
thank you all very much